Speaker 1: All right. A couple other little things
I want to check in on and then we'll do just a
brief election update based on the things that
have happened while we've been filming today. Our
good friends over at The Good Liars, that's Jason
and Dave. They spoke to a woman recently who says
that right now Dr. Fauci is in jail in Guantanamo
Bay. And it's not just Dr. Fauci, it's Obama,
and it's also Clinton.
Speaker 2: Obama. Now.
Speaker 1: I go back to the question we've
been trying to answer for a long time.
When? Is it a cult member with a cult
belief? When is it an ignorant person who
simply misinformed? If they're and if they're
shown the truth, they will revise their views.
And when is it mental illness? I don't know the
answer. Let's see if we can figure it out here.
Speaker 3: What do you think about Anthony Fauci?
Speaker 4: Oh, my God. I can't even believe
he made it this far. No, I just. The
guy guy's gone. He's he's in Gitmo.
Speaker 1: So.
Speaker 3:
Really, who else is in
Gitmo besides Anthony Fauci?
Speaker 4: You know, you got Hollywood there.
You've got politicians, you've got elites. The
Clintons are there. The Obamas are there. Wow. It
goes on and on. I don't want to be the one to sit
here and misquote somebody or say something, but.
Speaker 3: I don't want to
say anything irresponsible.
Speaker 1: Exactly right. Like Fauci,
Clinton and Obama are currently at Guantanamo
Bay. What do we do with this? What do we do?
Is this we need better education? Is this we
need antipsychotic medication? Like what is it
that needs to be done? The most actionable take
away at every election should be. She probably
voted yesterday, I guess. I mean, sometimes these
people are super involved in this superficial way,
but then they don't actually vote. But let's let's
assume she voted yesterday. We need to be voting
to counteract the vote of someone who thinks Dr.
Fauci is in prison. Right. Someone emailed me and
I don't know whether some of you think there's
something to this. Someone wrote to me and said,
you know, David, there's a reason why. It's mostly
like baby boomer types who we see repeating this
crazy conspiracy stuff that they get from Facebook
and elsewhere. This is this is the view of one of
our viewers. And what they said is baby boomers
simply didn't grow up with the Internet and social
media. People my age didn't grow up with it, but
it sort of cropped up when we were ten, 12, 14.
And then people like my little sisters age quite
literally grew up with that. And what this person
said is a lot of folks just don't understand
how to discern fake news and conspiracies.
And actual reliable information. They don't
know how to discern reliable and unreliable
Internet sources. A fake news website
is designed just like NewYorkTimes.com,
and they quite literally can't tell the
difference. I don't know. What is that? Is
that just. Is there something to the age thing?
I mean, my mom's never calling me and falling
for this stuff, so I don't know that that's really
what it's about. But it was an interesting idea.
Just so everybody knows, Dr. Fauci is not at
Guantanamo Bay. Barack Obama's also not there.
And neither Bill nor Hillary or even Chelsea
Clinton are being held at Guantanamo Bay.